Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question de Sheldon
et de sa classe de quatrième année à l'école Teueikan.
Kuei la gang, ça c'est mon école
où j'ai étudié quand j'étais petite.
Et Sheldon
me demande :
« Pourquoi est-ce que la chasse
est aussi important pour les Autochtones? »
Sheldon, c'est une très bonne question. Je pense qu'on ne chassait pas uniquement parce que c'était le plaisir
ou l'envie de tuer l'animal.
C'était vraiment qu'on s'est adapté
au territoire dans lequel on habitait. Si tu vas
dans le grand nord, tu peux voir qu'il y a
une impossibilité de faire pousser
des légumes, du maïs, de la courge
et des haricots.
Alors que si tu viens
dans la région de Montréal, c'était souvent
la source alimentaire la plus importante,
accompagneé avec du poisson et du chevreuil.
Donc on mangeait vraiment ce qui était
sur le territoire qu'on habitait.
Comme nous on est des Innus,
ce qu'on pouvait cueillir
était quand même très limité aux petits fruits.
Mais ce qu'on pouvait chasser, c'était
le caribou, c'était le castor, le porc-épic, le pékan.
Toutes les animaux
n'étaient pas non plus des animaux
pour être mangés. Il y avait des animaux
qui étaient utilisés pour s'habiller,
pour se protéger contre le froid.
Mais chaque animal, par exemple,
faisait partie d'un écosystème très fragile.
Donc on faisait extrêmement attention
de ne pas surchasser.
On chassait à certaines saisons
pour laisser l'animal tranquille
quand il se reproduisait.
Des fois, l'animal ne se présentait pas non plus
toute l'année. Je pense que présentement,
comme on est au printemps, on sait que
c'est la période des outardes et des canards.
Alors il y avait des cycles aussi
à la chasse pour donner une chance
à l'animal de revenir en force
chaque année et, pour nous, de pouvoir se nourrir.
Avec l'arrivée des Européens sont venus
la farine, les fruits, les légumes
et, bien sûr, aujourd'hui
avec les transports, avec le pétrole,
on peut avoir de l'alimentation
beaucoup plus variée.
Cependant, dans un principe d'écologie,
on favorisera toujours l'économie
et, je dirais, la nourriture locale,
parce qu'elle demande beaucoup moins
écologiquement et qu'elle est beaucoup
plus proche de ce qu'on avait besoin.
Je pense qu'on a vu au cours
des dernières années que manger uniquement
la nourriture qui vient du magasin
peut nous rendre malade,
parce qu'on a beaucoup de diabète, beaucoup
de maladies du coeur liées au fait qu'on mange
des aliments qui n'étaient pas les nôtres.
Et le fait qu on allait chercher notre
nourriture nous gardait en forme, aussi.
Donc ce sont des pratiques qui sont
encore excellentes pour nous, selon le
territoire dans lequel on habite,
si on les fait d'une façon raisonnable
et en respect avec nos traditions
pour justement garder cet équilibre-là.
Merci beaucoup Sheldon pour ta question.
J'espère que vous avez aimé la réponse,
j'espère que vous allez nous envoyer
des questions encore et je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine à Espaces autochtones.